día a día son muchos los policías en el
mundo y en colombia que entregan lo
mejor de sí mismo al servicio de los
demás
policías que dan la vida por alguien
desconocido
eso representa sacrificio vocación y
entrega para muchos
la policía es un mundo desconocido es un
mundo que solamente se percibe a partir
del uniforme o de los procedimientos que
realiza un policía o el cumplimiento del
deber que se transmite en algunos medios
de comunicación
sin embargo la policía es más que eso la
policía es una profesión que representa
mucho para la calidad de vida de los
ciudadanos en el mundo
de hecho cuando yo era pequeño parte de
mi infancia de mi adolescencia
transcurrió en unidades policiales mi
padre era un policía de vigilancia que
prestó sus servicios en el norte en el
sur del tolima y parte del departamento
del huila
también así en unas instalaciones
policiales mi vida transcurrió en medio
de una cultura policial marcada por
delincuencia por violencia pero también
por gratificaciones importantes que
tenía un policía para servir a la
ciudadanía
también entendí que el policía puede ser
incomprendido en muchos momentos pero
también puede ser muy útil para poder
solucionar los problemas a los
ciudadanos
al terminar mi bachillerato mi
secundaria
me incliné por la ingeniería de minas
pero en cuestión de seis meses terminé
haciendo trámites y gestiones para
ingresar a la academia policial a la
escuela general santander
pensé que tenía conciencia de lo que
quería hacer cuando fuera un adulto sin
embargo hasta allí no me había percatado
que gran parte de mi entorno familiar y
mi entorno como niño y adolescente
estaba marcado por una cultura policial
ingresé hace 30 años a la institución
policial
durante estos 30 años han transcurrido
muchas cosas en mi vida
y también recuerdo que gran parte de
estos 30 años han estado marcados
también por eso que viví en mi
adolescencia
45 años después
de haber vivido una infancia una
adolescencia marcado por los ritos y la
cultura policial pero también por mi
desarrollo profesional durante 30 años
de servicio me encontraba en la ciudad
de washington dice liderando un proyecto
que pretendía institucionalizar ameripol
al seno de la organización de estados
américanos durante la sustentación de
ese proyecto en una gran cumbre del
consejo de seguridad hemisférica tuve la
oportunidad de intercambiar en un
diálogo informal un par de palabras con
los embajadores y representantes de los
países
recuerdo que uno de los embajadores me
dijo
entendí a la policía como una persona
que simplemente toca un silbato o
recibir coimas en una calle
ese hecho significó mucho para mí y me
permitió interrogarme en ese momento
acerca de los niveles de eficacia
transparencia que de tener un cuerpo
policial pero también me permite
interrogar me acerca de la construcción
del futuro de la profesión y
especialmente del servicio de policía
para mí fue un hecho significativo
porque pese a lo que demuestra la
evidencia
que hay grandes resultados de las
policías en términos de capturas
convivencia
existe todavía un mega concepto mega
concepto erróneo para muchos
funcionarios y para gran parte de la
población acerca de lo que es el mundo
policial y lo que representa para
mejorar la calidad de vida de las
personas
de hecho posteriormente llegué a la
escuela de posgrados a nuestra academia
que forma el nivel directiva a los
líderes y mandos naturales de la policía
de colombia allí encontré un espacio
importante para poder gestionar el
futuro de la policía nacional de
colombia
el futuro de las nuevas generaciones de
las generaciones que se deduzcan y se
capacitan para liderar el cuerpo
policial
a mi llegada a colombia encontré un
espacio ideal
para preguntarnos cómo gestionar el
futuro de nuestra profesión de nuestro
servicio de policía allí con un equipo
humano
empezamos a encontrar el sentido a
nuestra profesión a descubrir los
atributos modernos que debe tener la
profesión
sus atributos deben estar marcados por
la orientación hacia el servicio por la
construcción de un marco conceptual y de
conocimiento científico de la profesión
pero también por poderla orientar hacia
los grandes desafíos y los grandes
amenazas que tiene nuestro mundo
pensar y repensar la profesión no se ha
implicado hacen un trabajo de
investigación aplicada para poder
construir esos atributos sus marcos
conceptuales arqueológicos y valorativos
de principios y valores que requieren
nuestra profesión
y posterior a ello
en la construcción de la mentalidad del
liderazgo
y descubrimos qué
hay una forma de aprender en las
policías se llama aprendizaje basado en
evidencia estoy implicado hacer
investigación aplicada mira el
territorio identificar las habilidades
las capacidades y los conocimientos que
debe tener un profesional de policía
y un tercer momento importante en la
construcción de este pensamiento ha sido
la elaboración de los diseños
curriculares o diseños educativos
que antes era algo intangible que no se
le daba mucho valor hoy en día los
diseños curriculares son la piedra
angular sobre la cual se desarrolla la
educación en la escuela de posgrados
llegar a diseños curriculares con nuevos
métodos ha implicado identificar de las
ciencias humanas de las ciencias
jurídicas de las ciencias de la
administración pública aquellos
elementos importantes del liderazgo de
integridad de ética de habilidades
sociales y comunicativas pero también de
habilidades técnicas y habilidades
científicas que debe manejar un líder
policial relacionadas con la gestión
territorial de la seguridad y la gestión
del servicio de policía los diseños
curriculares no se reducen solamente a
los planes de estudio la construcción de
los diseños curriculares hoy en día ha
implicado repensar el cuerpo de
profesores llegar a construir
un equipo de profesores altamente
comprometido que entienda la profesión
policial que entienda sus desafíos y las
tendencias de futuro hacia dónde va el
servicio y la profesión de policía
también ha implicado crear una nueva
infraestructura una infraestructura para
poder entrar para poner en práctica
todos los conocimientos que se ven en el
aula de clase
hemos encontrado nuevas tendencias y
nuevas prácticas para poder entrenar en
toma de decisiones a nuestros oficiales
de la policía de colombia ha sido un
espacio ideal por cuanto allí se genera
un conocimiento útil para el servicio de
la policía
todo esto no podía quedar solo sin la
tecnología creo que la tecnología es un
elemento sustancial hoy en día que nos
permite que las nuevas generaciones que
llegan a ser policías encuentren otros
mecanismos para poder aprender y también
los docentes para poder enseñar e
interactuar diferente en general creo
que construir la mentalidad del líder
policial implica todo un proceso desde
descubrir el sentido de la profesión
hasta descubrir nuevas metodologías y
nuevos métodos de aprendizaje de diseño
curricular de construcción de
infraestructura pero también de
ejercicio docente a las academias de
policía del mundo
dejamos un legado también para poder
inspirarlos y para que puedan seguir
convencidos que la educación del policía
representa mucho para poder ser
efectivos en la prestación de un
servicio la nueva mentalidad implica
poder construir educación una educación
ajustada a las realidades
creo que las amenazas y los desafíos que
tiene el mundo actualmente no se reducen
solamente a lo que pasa en la calle o
pasa en los campos de manera física
hoy en día necesitamos anticiparnos
genera una mentalidad de anticipación
para gestionar esas nuevas amenazas
nuestros ciudadanos nuestros niños
nuestros hijos requieren una protección
diferente lo que implica que la
profesión de policía debe pensarse hacia
el futuro durante muchos años nuestra
profesión ha estado más anclada en el
pasado
por la misma naturaleza que implica
nuestro servicio pero hoy el gran
desafío para todos los cuerpos
policiales está en el futuro allí en ese
espacio donde gran parte de nosotros
vamos a pasar nuestras vidas y ese
espacio tiene grandes retos tiene
grandes bondades para la humanidad pero
también requiere de líderes que puedan
anticiparse y puedan visualizar cuáles
son esos riesgos que vive nuestra
humanidad para adaptar el cuerpo de
policía a esas circunstancias si bien es
cierto que la educación de nuestras
policías no lo es todo
si me convenzo que la educación permite
encontrarle el sentido a nuestra
profesión
la educación es un espacio importante no
solamente para enseñar sino también para
investigar y para ubicar a nuestros
cuerpos policiales del mundo de la
región en el estadio que requerimos de
un cuerpo policía sin la educación
muchos esfuerzos en tecnología en
infraestructura
estarían en vano creo que la educación
ocupa un espacio importante y puede
representar un cambio a futuro de
nuestra profesión de su ejercicio pero
en especial de sus logros en clave de
las nuevas amenazas y riesgos que vienen
esta mañana
[Aplausos]